Good old-fashioned goats,
and the ancient Hindu practice of yoga.
Two things that don't seem to go together.
You got peanut butter in my chocolate!
But one year ago a small farm in Oregon invented
goat yoga.
And the unlikely trend spread across the nation
until it reached the east coast,
when the unstoppable force of goat yoga
met the immovable object of the Washington
DC Deparment of Health.
Goat yoga is literally we do yoga as a class,
40 minutes,
and we just have the goats hang out with us.
So we would go through the different asanas
and the different flows
and the goats will come around and interact
with people as we're doing the class.
So they may walk up to somebody and sniff
their nose, maybe nibble on some toes,
and if they're feeling brave enough or want
to they might jump on them
or give them a kiss or something.
DC is not very livestock oriented.
I know it was a big thing with the Health
Department though,
they asked us to do a lot of things with our
vet certifications,
health certificates and things like that
and we did everything they asked
and they ended up squashing it anyway.
Congressional Cemetery is a historic cemetery
founded in 1807.
It is a private cemetery, home to about 160
markers for individual congressmen.
We opened up our chapel every Wednesday night
to a yoga instructor.
We call it Yoga Mortis.
There are some who find their inner peace
next to dead people.
Corpse pose.
We've had goats to eat all of our invasive
species in our forested area of the cemetery.
So we thought, why not combine baby goats
and yoga.
We knew we would need a permit for that because
we're bringing in livestock into the district.
And so we went to the Department of Health
to obtain that permit.
And when I went down to meet with them it
was in a conference room
the director was there which kind of surprised
me.
and about four lawyers were there
with all of the rules and regulations open on their laptops
ready to kind of throw every curve ball they
possibly could at me
to prevent goat yoga.
Goats have been domesticated for about 6000
years,
but they required that we obtain a wildlife
handler's certificate
for our goat farmer.
They initially were worried that someone would
fall during a yoga class or an exercise
and hurt a baby goat, which is really difficult
to do,
if you've ever been around a herd of goats,
especially babies,
they are constantly falling down, jumping
on each other, jumping on rocks,
really having the time of their life.
But what if the goats are not having the time
of their lives?
What if the department of health was right
when it told Washingtonian Magazine:
"Any time animals come into the District,
we want to make sure they are safe
and not being put into a position of harm."
Expressing "concern for the safety of the
animals should someone ever fall over one."
and deeming goat yoga "a violation of a 'no
touch' policy
by spectators for animals participating in
District events."
Mount Vernon Square neighborhood had a petting
zoo four youngsters
and they had far more exotic animals than
goats, they even had a llama,
which is a pretty vile animal if you've ever
been around a spitting llama.
But they allowed a lot of this 'no touching'
to actually happen at that petting zoo.
There's no reason that you can't do goat yoga.
Great, what's next, uh, llama yoga?